cd projekt red has some things to talk
about capcom is counting down to a game
reveal and more
cd projekt red has announced a very
special video briefing that's coming up
pretty soon the polish developer will
hold a new red streams event tomorrow
february 15th where it will talk about
items related to cyberpunk 2077 but what
can we expect things you know cd projekt
said the event kicks off at 4 pm central
which is 7am pacific and a.m eastern
gamespot will bring you all the news as
it happens cd projekt did not tease
anything about what to expect but the
announcement came from the cyberpunk
2077 twitter account so an update on the
game's ps5 and xbox series and s edition
might be coming recently a ps5 edition
of cyberpunk 2077 was spotted on the
playstation network and the game was
confirmed and optimized for xbox series
x and s suggesting the official
announcement and launch might be coming
up soon could it be tomorrow or could
they possibly get two birds with one
stone and also drop some witcher news
we'll just have to wait and see
a timer on the capcom website is
currently counting down to something but
the video game company has not yet
revealed what will be seen once the
clock counts down to zero currently
scheduled to end february 20th and 21st
at 10 a.m pacific and 1 a.m eastern
speculation on the upcoming reveal
focused on a possible street fighter
announcement the evidence certainly
lines up as capcom's three-day
tournament the street fighter pro tour
season final is scheduled to conclude at
that hour 2022 also marks the 35th
anniversary of street fighter an event
which capcom acknowledged by telling
fans to look forward to the future
development of the street fighter series
in january the countdown could also be
subtly alluding to another one of
capcom's popular franchises as the font
used for the numbers bury striking
resemblance to the text used for the
recent resident evil games and remakes
resident evil 4 remake is rumored to be
in development and will reportedly have
a more horror influence atmosphere in
comparison to the original game's
action-packed design
dying light to stay human's post-launch
support is well underway with the game's
first free dlc launching today called
the authority pack players can represent
the peacekeepers with a suite of new
armor and a new weapon while the
authority pack is out now for anyone to
download players will only have access
to one third of its content today
players can pick up an intimidating
jacket along with matching cargo pants
and high tops but that's it another part
of the pack is set to release in just
two days on february 16th and will
include another matching set of
intimidating gauntlets a windbreaker and
leather guards the pack's final bit of
content will be released this friday
february 18th consisting of a single
two-handed authority hammer dying light
2's second free dlc pack has also been
announced although without a date
whenever it launches the ronin pack will
let players leap around vallador dressed
as a samurai and hack the undead in two
with a unique sword and in case you
missed it we have a hilarious glitch
compilation over on our channel right
now just for dying light too admittedly
these two free expansions are pretty
light on content though they're just the
start of dying light 2's post launch
support techland has already committed
to bringing new content to the game for
the next five years at least a more
immediate map for dying light 2 includes
a new set of challenges coming in march
mutated infected events in april and its
first paid story dlc showing up in june
and speaking of new content call of duty
war zone season 2 just dropped today so
if you need something to do before all
of these upcoming announcements check
out the patch notes on gamespot.com
and before you go let me know in the
comments which capcom series you want to
see a new title for and why
alright leave a like subscribe and thank
you so much for watching see you next
time
[Music]
you